welcome to this video playing Apollo
Creed Apollo Creed coming back from the
dead after he was killed by even Drago
in rocky fought yeah but he's playing
against me what can I do I cannot
complain that he's actually dead okay
let's see we have the arbor back in the
Kings in yet yeah we should a foyer I
know I tend to play this move let's see
what he's doing just six probably what
normally goes for this capture in the
armored bug trying to prove that he has
a slight advantage in this type of
position here which will not be easy but
one thing that why definitely has going
for him this is a very solid solid
position i am here 94 is probably
probably good for black right yeah yeah
yeah i mean good in the sense of being
okay okay probably not much to do
against it
I shouldn't play 94 as a pre-movie I
yeah black black n can play other mousse
okay Bishop d3 maybe m2 now they can
still play 90 for the output anyway and
this is probably what I did there the
whole thing is probably to toothless
yeah it's not presenting black with any
serious challenge now sometimes you can
do funny things here like trying to cap
captured piece but won't work here came
the rook is attacking c2 and c4 yeah
maybe Here I am I have to play be three
anyway I think lending some support here
and I have to move the rock to play b3j
not much not much happening tween t 392
I'm not going to catch this rook I guess
now what you sometimes can do in this
type of positions you can try to press
in a minor piece and game when you get
them rooks queen everything off and then
why does enjoying some some space
advantage which is nothing serious but
something that you can try to play a
platform okay maybe just rupee one here
yeah as mentioned I don't mind- trades
these trades
i might play Queen a one at the end
after we have traded I know k wants to
do this push ups III is some blundering
stuff I'm not really but I can take here
and now i don't know this is probably
not a transformation that black welcomes
very much the shop here and then III
before maybe I don't know maybe I should
have prevented you for it's always
tricky tricky question
okay and now a 3 beef is or should I go
f3 first yeah I'd like to make him play
a five at least weaken his structure a
little bit
Wow
some neighbor trying to break the wall
down sounds kinda weird okay like before
now or before and then see 5 or is this
too brutal I don't know I want you I
don't want to fall too much behind on
the clock and I can I can pre move this
pawn takes Bishop takes and then I'm
going to take before yeah with what
actually with the pin maybe with the
bishop to get in d6 get in d6 and is fo
I am
now yes the immediately for were just
quite quite strong okay
Queen d3 Queen f3 I don't know yeah this
I porn is really really a problem oh
come on you don't want to drill all day
right I really hate it if there's some
noise when I play normally do into total
nonsense then let's hope it's not
happening here position is tricky anyway
once the support with bishop age 6 okay
I thought rook e1 now should win the
porn not for a win but maybe for for
some dro or something okay okay rook
takes rook takes Queen takes Bishop
takes but then queen t to the spaceship
c5 check so his driver is just about
holding unless unless I have King h1 and
trying they're moving out of the checks
I hope I'm not
were playing my hand here I might yeah
yeah not good look into I cannot I
should have taken all that yeah I should
have taken I'm stupid I really should
have just taken down
oh come on now I'm lost no and I'm just
a stupid idiot yeah i justjust take this
damn draw with no time on the clock it's
just just total stupidity you can just
take c5 like we never won check check
this is so alright Queenie 7 might be a
draw if it takes the rook but I'm
definitely lost here somehow check check
check check I can play this move ah come
on air when I am on a stupid idiot
really a stupid idiot i'm gifting away
points they're like no tomorrow Bishop
c5 yes yeah I should just I should just
take here and it's it's it's over yeah
in terms of anything happening I can
just do this and and I'm and it's equal
at least yeah of course I wanted to win
because I was definitely a better yeah
little bit but okay it wasn't really
enough to to win yeah hxs betcha yeah
because of root k 1 yes I was thinking
that I had the idea when I played this
one of d 6 obviously and andrew c 7 but
the e porn is just just too quick it
gives black clearly enough counter play
to secure the draw but I should really
secure the draw yeah I should have taken
I mean probably this is already malice
has already lost him
yeah check check and this is a check
check with Queen ever check yeah
whatever I mean I have five seconds here
38 will be no time okay thanks for
watching